salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous avez déjà entendu parler du
tourisme
écoresponsable c'est une façon de
voyager tout en respectant
l'environnement c'est justement la
spécialité de Tolt avec lui nous partons
aujourd'hui pour un joli périple qui
démarre dans le Nord à Lille et qui va
nous entraîner jusque dans la région de
Saint-Étienne nous allons découvrir le B
frroid de la capitale des Flandres le
plus haut d'Europe et nous saons enfin
si les frites sont françaises ou belges
puis nous apprendrons comment se sont
formé les méandres de la loi et vous
verrez que ça souffle aussi pas mal de
ce côté je veux parler de la fabrication
artisanale du verre attention au
départ changer d'air sans émettre de
co2ou vraiment très peu c'est possible
avec le vélo et le train sur un Paris
Lille par exemple chaque voyageur émett
en moyenne 1 kg de CO2 en prenant le
train en voiture s'il n'y a qu'un seul
passager à bord et bien ses émissions
s'élèvent à 23 kg c'est justement en
train que Tolt a choisi de se rendre
dans la capitale d'flandre en plus Paris
en train c'est très rapide on met
beaucoup moins de temps qu'en voiture
salut jamis je te confirme que c'est
plus rapide puisque le trajet dure très
exactement 1h 6 minutes c'est même moins
long que de traverser Paris en voiture
aux heures de pointe et l'île est très
bien desservie par le rail on est ici
dans une sorte de Carrefour mais surtout
il y a ici un réseau régional super
efficace qui permet de découvrir les
plages du nord très rapidement aller à
Berque au Touquet ou encore en bom avant
de découvrir la plage il y a l'île et
dans la capitale des Flandres le
monument vers lequel se tourne tous les
regards lorsqu'on sort de la gare c'est
évidemment le B frroid oui c'est le
point de repère pour tous les Lillois le
fameux B frroid de l'Hôtel de Ville
regardez ça s'il est pas beau ce B
frroid vu d'en bas c'est vraiment
impressionnant il fait 104 m c'est le
plus haut d'Europe c'est aussi le
symbole de la ville on l'appelle
d'ailleurs le grciel des Flandres il est
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO depuis 2005 mais attention
c'est pas le seul c'est aussi le cas
pour 22 deux autres B frroid dans la
région donc vous l'aurez compris dans le
Nord on en trouve partout effectivement
les BA frroids font partie intégrante du
paysage la région Haut- de France en
compte 44 leur origine remonte au 11e
siècle on les érigeait dans les villes
qui avaient obtenu leur indépendance
vis-à-vis des seigneurs locaux une façon
pour ces villes d'affirmer leur
puissance c'était l'équivalent du donjon
elle pouvait servir de tour de gay mais
pas que la plupart possèdent une cloche
au sommet autrefois elle sonnait
régulièrement entre autres pour indiquer
l'heure aux habitants mais choses très
surprenant le B frroid de l'Hôtel de
Ville de Lille qui est bien plus récent
il a été inauguré en 1932 n'en possède
pas en fait à la fin des travaux les
constructeurs se sont rendus compte
qu'aucune cloche digne de ce nom ne
pouvait franchir les portes du coup
c'est le seul B frroid sans cloche mais
cet édifice est une véritable prouesse
architecturale c'est le premier bâtiment
Français de plus de 100 m de hauteur
entièrement réalisé en béton armé pas de
cloche mais un ascenseur qui de toute
façon ne servira pas à Tolt puisqu'il se
déplace en train à vélo et à pied allez
encore un petit effort 398 399 400 et
voilà nous voici enfin arrivés en haut
des 400 marches du B frroid c'est assez
sportif mais honnêtement ça vaut le coup
regardez-moi cette
vue j'arrête pas de voir des gens manger
ça m'a ouvert l'appétit et ce qui est
cool à l c'est qu'il y a plein de bonnes
adresses mais aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie
de vous emmener dans un restaurant j'ai
envie de vous emmener dans un festival
de Food truck comme c'est un peu loin on
va prendre un taxiange plaisante vous
connaissez on va y à
vélo il y a des vélos en libre service à
Lille mais comme on va devoir sortir de
la ville en fin de journée on va plutôt
passer par un loueur
traditionnel ici de plus en plus de gens
utilisent ce mode otion pour se déplacer
il faut dire que la municipalité fait
tout pour faciliter l'accès au vélo
l'île veut faire partie du peloton de
tête des plus grandes agglomérations
cyclables de France elle compte
d'ailleurs déjà plus de 150 km de piste
réservé au vélo me voilà arrivé devant
un bâtiment assez impressionnant
puisqu'il s'agit d'une ancienne
manufacture textile aujourd'hui c'est
l'un des plus grands incubateurs de
start-up
[Musique]
d'Europe j'ai jamais vu autant de fot
truck le but c'est de faire découvrir la
cuisine du monde au lillois on trouve
des tacos des burgers et aussi des
ramenes un plat japonais à base de
[Musique]
nouille mais évidemment nous sommes à
Lille et ici le plat incontournable ce
sont les frites et ça tombe bien j'ai
rendez-vous avec le chef Florent Laden
il paraî que ces frites sont les
meilleur de la région bon alors tu as
choisi quelle variété de pommes de terre
pour faire tes frites et surtout
pourquoi alors là on est sur une variété
très locale qui est produite en plus par
par Joseph le voisin qui m'a tenu dans
les bras quand j'étais petit c'est la
Binch parce qu'en ce moment c'est la
meilleure c'est quoi justement ta
recette à toi qu-ce qui fait qu'elle est
si spéciale nous notre secret c'est de
rien inventer de rien changer la
tradition c'est de respecter le fait de
faire les frites au gras de bœuf de les
faire en deux cuissons un premier bain à
130°r à la coule pour rendre la pomme de
terre purée et un deuxième bain à
température plus élevée pour vraiment
saisir pour avoir la croustillance parce
que une bonne frite c'est de la purée au
cœur mais la croustillance et alors
dernière question pour finir qui
peut-être fâche un peu selon toi les
frites c'est belge ou c'est français je
peux pas me faire de potte làdessus
parce que moi je suis flamand de France
j'ai grandi sur la sur la frontière et
je pense que ça a été créé un endroit où
où la frontière Francobelge était pas
aussi définie et dessinée qu'aujourd'hui
bon bah Florent il veut pas trop se
mouiller visiblement et toi Jamie tu en
penses quoi pour nous Français c'est
évident les frites viennent de France
mais pour les Belges elles sont belges
alors qui a tort qui a raison les deux
mon capitaine les frites auraient été
inventées au 17e siècle dans la ville de
Namur à 70 km au sud de Bruxelles pour
leur repas les habitants de cette ville
avaient l'habitude de faire frire du
poisson qu'il pêchait dans la Meuse mais
lors d'un hiver particulièrement
rigoureux la Meuse a gelé impossible de
pêcher les Namurois auraient alors eu
une idée de génie remplacer les poissons
par des pommes de terre découpé en
bâtonnet des pommes de terre frites
elles aussi voilà comment les Belges
auraient inventé les frites excuse-moi
jamis mais moi il me semble avoir
entendu que la frite avait vu le jour à
Paris j'y viens cette histoire de gelé
et de pommes de terre frit pour
remplacer les poissons n'a jamais été
prouvé d'ailleurs elle tiendrait
davantage de la légende selon certains
historiens elles auraient en effet été
inventées sur les bords de la scène à la
fin du 18e siècle ou au début du 19e à
l'époque sur le pont Neuf des vendeuses
ont l'idée de tremper des pommes de
terre découpées en rondelle dans une
friture de sainddou elles vendent leur
savoureuses pommes du pont neœuf aux
spectateurs des nombre théâtre installé
dans le quartier on dit que baudelair et
Victor Hugo en rafolai après les années
30 on finit par abandonner les rondelles
au profit des bâtonnés bien plus
pratique car ils ne collent pas entre
eux à la cuisson c'est donc bien en
France que sont nés les frites teles que
nous les connaissons aujourd'hui il ne
faut pas négliger le rôle joué par les
Belges ce sont eux qui ont rendu les
frites célèbres dans le monde entier
grâce un Allemand un certain
jean-fédéric kriger ce forain originaire
de Bavière ouvre la première baraque à
frit de Belgique en
1844 il y propose des pommes de terre
frit à la parisienne surnommé le roi de
la frite il rencontre un succès fou dans
toutes les foires du plat pays et très
vite les frites deviennent un classique
de la cuisine belge en résumé ce sont
donc les Français qui ont inventé les
frites mais ce sont les Belges qui les
ont rendu célèbre dans le monde entier
allez direction la forêt de fallalempin
j'y vais pas pour ramasser les
champignons c'est là-bas que je vais
passer la nuit mais avant ça je vais
regarder l'itinéraire sur mon
application ça te permet de trouver le
meilleur itinéraire pour les vélos en te
faisant passer par un maximum de voies
aménager ah oui quand même 1h22 bon ben
on va y aller
[Musique]
peut-être vous allez voir j'ai réservé
un hébergement pas comme les autres une
énorme cabane perchée à 8 m de hauteur
bon évidemment il faut pas trop avoir le
[Musique]
vertige ici pas de douche juste des
toilettes sèches et un grand lit avec vu
sur la forêt avec un peu de chance je
pourrais peut-être voir un chevreuil un
renard ou même un
écureuil
ah je sens que je vais passer une bonne
nuit et c'est pas une mauvaise chose
parce que demain j'ai rendez-vous du
côté de Saint-Étienne pour découvrir les
gorges de la Loire au programme on a
deux TGV et un TER à prendre et cette
fois-ci je vais pouvoir embarquer mon
vélo mais en tout cas j'ai hâte de
découvrir ces
paysages autrefois les vélos étaient
considérés comme de simples bagages dans
le train on les transportait
gratuitement dans des vagons prévus à
cet effet en
1898 certains jours on a pu enregistrer
jusqu'à 3000 bicyclettes dans les gares
parisiennes un record mais tout change
un siècle plus tard dans les années 1970
ces fameux wagons sont peu à peu
supprimés et les guichets à bagage
ferment les uns après les autres le
service est définitivement supprimé en
1998 cette décision provoque un
véritable tolé les associations de
cyclistes se mobilisent auprès de la
SNCF afin qu'un service soit rétabli au
plus vite aujourd'hui il est donc à
nouveau possible d'emporter avec soi son
vélo sur la plupart des trajets à une
condition il doit être démonté et rangé
dans une housse comme un simple bagage
si votre bicyclette ne se démonte pas
sachez cependant qu'il existe des
espaces prévus à cet effet mais
uniquement dans certains TGV et TER
renseignez-vous avant de partir on y
suspend son vélo à un crochet ça prend
moins de place si comme moi vous voulez
voyager en train avec votre vélo
l'option vous coûtera 10 € dans un TGV
mais sinon dans ce TER de Lyon à
Saint-Étienne c'est
gratuit
voilà maintenant j'ai plus qu'une
grosseur de vélo pour rejoindre
Saint-Victor surloire vous allez voir
les panoramas sont à couper le
[Musique]
souffle j'arrive sur le python rocheux
du plateau de la danse attention il faut
pousser son vélo sur les derniers mètres
mais franchement c'est le meilleur spot
pour découvrir les gorges de la Loire
franchement c'est pas trop beau vous
voyez ici le paysage est super contrasté
on peut voir des forêts des falaises des
Landes un peu plus loin là-bas on a le
port de Saint-Victor sur Loire et encore
plus loin on peut apercevoir le Château
de grand Jean perché sur son île et
là-bas là-haut là c'est le château des
Salois franchement c'est à tomber fais
attention à toi quand même ces gorges
offrent un panorama unique ell s'étir
sur 24 km depuis orec surloire jusqu'à
Saint-Juste Saint-Rambert elles ont été
creusées par le fleuve pendant des
millions d'années il s'est frayé un
passage dans le plateau granitique qui
sépare les monts du forê et le massif du
Pilard c'est une très vieille chaîne de
montagne formée il y a 300 millions
d'années la chaîne hersiniienne la Loire
il a sculpé ses méandres et creusé son
cours parfois sur plusieurs centaines de
mètres au milieu du 20e siècle le
paysage a été transformé par la
construction du barrage hydroélectrique
de grandjan le mur de béton de 55 m de
hauteur barre la Loire et forme une
retenue qui s'étend sur 400 haectares
presque 400 terrain de football elle
s'étire sur 21 km cette opération a
englouti les anciens ponts les viaducs
et les voies ferrées désormais les
gorges de la Loire ont un petit air de
fiorde forésien pour les arpentés il
existe plus de 50 itinéraire de randonné
pédestre signalisé des circuits qui vont
d'unh à 6h de marche sinon vous pouvez
faire comme Tolt utiliser des pistes
vertes qui ont été balisées pour
circuler à
VTT j'ai quitté les gorges pour
saintgalmier la ville qui pétille et
pour cause c'est ici qu'on trouve la
source d'une célèbre e pétillante
minérale elle est mise en bouteille ici
même depuis
1837 Saint-Galmier se situe au cœur du
Massif central à la croisée des Monds du
Lyonnais et de la plaine du forz et vous
allez voir qu'ici on ne produit pas que
de l'eau l'attraction à ne pas louper
c'est l'atelier de Pierre Marion il est
souffleur de verre ou plus précisément
de cristal mais bon pas le temps de
souffler je vais aller lui rendre une
petite
visite bonjour Tolt comment ça va bien
bienon alors là on est dans ton atelier
en plein air où tu confectionnes des
pièces à partir de cristal recyclé c'est
les pièces qu'on voit là-bas sur les
étagères est-ce que tu peux nous en dire
un peu plus sur les outils que tu
utilises alors c'est le four bien sûr
puisque c'est là où se trouve la matière
en fusion les outils c'est les cannes
pour souffler les pièces c'est une canne
un tube en métal en inox et le bout de
la canne qu'on appelle le mort de la
canne lui il est en acierre réfractaire
justement pour supporter des
températures bien élevées de l'ordre de
12 100°r quoi alors est-ce que tu peux
nous décrire un peu plus précisément la
canne à souffler quelle taille elle fait
quel diamètre c'est un peu comme une
serbanne donc ça fait à peu près 1 cm 1
cm demi maximum de diamètre de diamètre
ouais et en longueur ça fait 1,20 à peu
près est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer
pas à pas tout le processus de création
d'une pièce alors on prend déjà une
canne si on veut faire une pièce colorée
on met un morceau de couleur au bout
bout de la canne on le fait fondre on
souffle un peu dans la canne pour
introduire déjà une toute petite bulle
d'air on appelle ça une poste on la
laisse refroidir après on va la plonger
dans un bain de cristal en fusion qui
est à peu près à 1100 1150° après donc
on recouvre cette poste de couleur avec
une couche de cristal transparent on le
centre à nouveau ce cristal transparent
autour de cette poste de couleur on la
laisse devenir un peu rigide et on va
prendre des morceaux de couleur qu'on va
ajouter par endroit sur cette masse de
cristal transparent on va retourner à
nouveau dans le four de fusion où se
trouve le cristal transparent pour
remettre une couche de cristal
par-dessus ça permet d'avoir plus de
matière toutes ces couches donc on peut
mettre en fait c ou si couches de
cristal les unes par-dessus les autres
faut pas en mettre plus après parce que
tuarrive plus à le porter ou al moins
d'être très costaud et ensuite seulement
on souffle le vas une fois qu'elle est
terminée on peut pas la laisser
refroidir comme ça à l'air libre ou dans
l'atelier elle casserait il y a encore
un autre four qu'on appelle le four de
recuisson et et c'est pendant la nuit
que les pièces vont refroidir tout
doucement donc on les sort seulement le
lendemain et certaines pièces très
épaisses ça peut nécessiter plus de 24
heur pour refroidir figurez-vous que les
pièces de cristal soufflé par Pierre
séduisent bien au-delà de la région
puisque même Madonna la reine de la pop
lui a commandé plusieurs flacons comme
celui-ci la classe non le cristal a été
mis au point au 17e siècle par un
marchand verrier anglais George
Ravenscroft il aurait découvert ce
nouveau matériau par hasard en ajoutant
de l'oxyde de plomb dans la recette du
ver
le verre est obtenu en faisant fondre du
sable de la silice précisément à
laquelle on ajoute de la soude afin de
faire baisser la température de fusion
en ajoutant de l'oxyde de plomb et en
faisant cuire ce mélange pendant au
moins 36 he à
1450° on obtient du cristal ce matériau
possède une densité plus élevée que le
verre il est aussi plus dur et en prime
il a un éclat
extraordinaire voilà j'amis j'arrive au
bout de mon périple et ce soir je dors
dans un château chiicenant j'ai parcouru
plus de 1400 km entre Paris Lille et
Saint-Étienne et je suis super fier de
moi parce que j'ai réussi à émettre à
peu près 50 fois moins de gaz à effet de
serre que si j'avais pris la voiture
Jamie la prochaine fois tu viens avec
moi avec grand plaisir tot je prendrai
peut-être mon vélo électrique voilà
j'espère que notre petit périple à la
découverte des trésors de lî et de la
région de Saint-Étienne vous a plu
surtout qu'il vous a convaincu qu'on
peut faire de beaux voyages et de très
belles rencontres tout en respectant
l'environnement je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine et d'ici là passer
d'excellents moments sur les réseaux
avec les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
épurieux